this is just the beginning of the south
pacific storm season and cyclone yasser
ensured it was a destructive start the
category 5 storm came ashore with wind
gusts
of up to 345 kilometers an hour
houses and other buildings were
destroyed and crops flattened
and we will continue to assess the scale
of damage in the coming days
but we are likely looking at hundreds of
millions of dollars
in damages still it could have been much
worse a late change of direction
meant the capital suva avoided a direct
hit
as it was more than 93 000 people were
in the storm's path
and more than 23 000 went to evacuation
fijians centers used to cyclones but
they're happening more often
and becoming more dangerous and the
prime minister blames climate change
as the world is getting warmer these
storms
are getting stronger every one of us
must treat these climate fuel
catastrophes
with deadly seriousness this storm
season could be particularly painful for
fijians whose economy which is reliant
on foreign tourists
has been badly affected by the
coronavirus pandemic
wayne hey al jazeera auckland